do you guys have anybody that you go
like oh this would be my
love out there and this would be mine
because i i think i heard a rumor that
maybe
we might have the same
crap person out there in the world who
really does it for us i want to hear who
is it mr letterman oh my gosh
for real yes
oh
he was just so arthritis i told him
100 david letterman so have you ever met
mr letterman i haven't do you like
wonder what mr letterman would think of
joanna gaines i don't know if he would
know julian again
emma would you please roll the tape
joanna oh whoa i'm i'm overwhelmed by
your interest and attention in what i
used to refer to as
a career
and thanks for watching you'd probably
be the only one anyway
gosh i wish i could be there with you in
texas i'm in uh
hawaii right now i'm learning to surf
having a lot of fun
i hope to see you in person one day
joanna thank you very much for
everything yay
um
what
you know again
i'm talking like oprah and martha and a
very few select group of people who have
been able to achieve
having your own network having your own
magazine
having i mean you guys are taking over
the world you're doing it you know
congratulations
and thank you because you have made the
world a better place from this town
inside out to the rest of the globe
did any of that seem like the goal
ironically you were in commercials so
it's like there was some drama i always
thought i'd be a broadcast journalist
yeah but not enough rather good
spontaneous like
reality television it was really i want
a teleprompter you need to help me with
what i'm gonna say
in that moment because i'm the type at
that news desk if that teleprompter goes
out i have nothing to say i'm like i
freeze and so for me
a lot of just my past and being half
korean like i built up a lot of walls
just being made fun of in the school
room you know stuff like that so what
happened is i would put up a lot of
walls and i would let the world only see
this side of me because i was like maybe
what's back here isn't good you know i
processed that and dealt with that as a
little girl so now i'm in new york city
internship and then what i when i
started working at that real job i
started realizing at the same time when
i'd go back home at my in my apartment
in new york i would start writing i
would just write and all of a sudden
what was coming out are things from
kindergarten first grade second grade
like all those moments of pain and i
started playing this game with myself
like hey all those moments of pain how
do we turn that into beauty and i kind
of started this like healing process
as a 21 year old woman in new york city
i was so lonely i was doing a job and i
was like i don't think i want to do this
anymore but as i started doing that job
but i would come home and work on myself
by the time i left new york city i
didn't want to do that anymore because i
started really loving who was coming out
in that healing process so the walls
came down and the realization rose to
the top rose to the top and i was like
wait my story is incredible i love that
i'm half i love my mother's culture i
started embracing it and saying if you
don't like me because of that that's you
know
i'm sorry but this is who i am and your
mother is korean korean her father met
her in the war stationed there german
and lebanese yes do you you know that is
your heritage do you bring your children
into it you found your pride your
parents how do you honor that heritage
well thankfully my mother lives here in
waco with us and so one of the things
anytime we get together she's always
making korean food and since all of my
kids were
tiny like 10 months when they started
eating soup grandma's food was their
favorite she would make all this korean
soup they eat seaweed like they would
take seaweed to lunch so my kids don't
look korean but when you look at their
lunch boxes you're like wait what so i
feel like they love that side they love
grandma and all that she really stands
for so for me it's so important i feel a
cookbook
you and your mom
i'm actually getting my korean aunt who
um she did an episode with me here
during the the cooking show
um but i'm trying to get her to come
back down for two weeks and teach me all
the things my mother wasn't her mother
was a really great cook and then my mom
kind of was like oh i missed a lot of
that along the way so my aunt i'm trying
to get her here better than you to take
your family's culinary heritage and
matriculate it into a cookbook everyone
would
you know open your horizons
[Music]